the critics have seen the fourth John
Wick flick and yeah they're thinking
he's back here's what early reviews have
to say about the latest installment and
the Unstoppable Hitman franchise people
keep asking if I'm back and I haven't
really had an answer
but now yeah I'm thinking I'm back the
much anticipated John weight chapter 4
will hit movie theaters worldwide on
March 24th but the review embargo for
the Keanu Reeves LED Blockbuster has
already been lifted and the vast
majority of critics are heaping Praise
on it the fourth iteration of The Saga
holds an 88 critic score on Rotten
Tomatoes with 26 reviews as of the
making of this video Chapter 4 is filled
with things that happen in every John
Wick movie with the most important of
those being over-the-top combat
sequences happening at a Breakneck Pace
this time around director Chad
stachelski has taken viewers on a
journey across a number of different
locations spread else across three
continents clocking in at a whopping 162
minutes of runtime chapter 4 follows the
titular character as he strives to break
free from the high table once and for
all nearly three hours might seem like
overkill for an action-focused film
where the plot plays second fiddle but
says most of the reviews suggest it was
a conscious decision
part varieties Owen Glebe monroes is
chapter four too long you bet it is at
moments it's like an action film as
liturgical church service Yet the movie
is conceived as a knowingly overstuffed
gift to John Wick fans and on that level
it succeeds it's like Sergio Leone
crossed with John Woo a scene in Times
Square One thing that all of the chapter
4 reviewers highlighted in fact was the
fact that the movie is by far the
longest in the franchise they were full
of praise for stahlski's ability to keep
viewers engaged for so long while
maintaining consistently high quality
odn's Tom Georgian Sun even called it a
modern action masterclass and gave the
movie a rare score of 10 out of 10
writing in an age of increased
grumblings about films of two plus hour
run times chapter 4's roaring Pace
serves as a counter argument that
proclaims movies should be as long as
they need to be writing for BBC culture
Karen James praised the visuals and
choreography writing knives guns and
martial arts come into play often in
lovely red tins light to the sound of
glass shattering all around John Wick
goes full James Bond globetrotting and
shooting his way through glamorous
cities with action that is even more
spectacularly staged citing the gripping
combat scenes and praising the work of
the stunt team the Hollywood reports
says Frank Sheck wrote that chapter 4
out does its predecessors in nearly
every respect this sentiment prevails in
other reviews with Eric Eisenberg
writing for Cinema blender there's a
strong argument to be made that it's the
best of the sequels and the digital
spies Ian Sandwell summing it up as not
bad for a series that started out with a
Hitman avenging his dead puppy according
to most critics the action in chapter 4
is so good that it excuses the
shortcomings of its plot at one point in
her review for Entertainment Weekly Leah
Greenblatt posed the question how does
nearly three hours of wam bam noise and
nonsense and mitigated by any meaningful
plots work as well as it does she went
on to answer it by pointing toward Keanu
Reeves ability to remain likable despite
playing a mass murdering Hitman writing
that there's quote something ineffable
in Reeves that you can't help but root
for Nick Shaker of The Daily Beast
emphasize how the actor expresses his
character without much dialogue writing
letting his stairs and homicidal skills
do the talking for him Reeves exudes
typically fearsome gravity purpose and
weariness in a sunshine state Cineplex
review and then French went further
writing Reeve shows why he's one of the
best genre actors in the world and pause
his heart and soul into a soft-spoken
performance good luck Mr Wick
thanks Doug although he makes all the
stunts and fast-paced combat seem easy
Reeves admitted in a recent Fandango
interview that chapter 4 was the hardest
film he's ever done but based on early
reviews it looks like it was worth all
the effort
foreign